let's talk a little bit about property
insurance the first question is why
would you want to insure property well
for a lot of folks their property is a
lot of uh the most expensive things they
have that would be very hard to replace
if something bad happened to it
and there's two big categories of
property insurance you have renters
insurance and you have homeowners
insurance
now as you can imagine renters assure
renters insurance is good for renters
and what would it cover well let's say
you are renting an apartment but you own
the furniture you own maybe some of the
appliances your laptop is in the
apartment you have a big screen TV you
have a stereo whatever else you have it
could have a lot of value to it and now
let's say something bad happened maybe
the building
maybe there was a an earthquake or a
fire or a flood and a lot of that stuff
got damaged and it would be hard for you
out of pocket just out of your own uh
with your own money to to buy all that
stuff back it would take a big hit and
so that's what renters insurance would
cover you would pay a certain amount on
a regular basis on an annual basis that
is your premium and that if and there's
they usually list the scenarios maybe
there's theft maybe you got burglarized
maybe the place burned down whatever the
scenarios that they list in those
scenarios if your property got lost or
damaged or destroyed or stolen then they
will pay you back for that
now homeowners insurance is an extension
of it but when you're a homeowner you
don't just own the furniture and the
electronics inside the house you own the
entire house and as you can imagine a
house itself can be a lot more expensive
than let's say the furniture inside of
the house and so homeowners insurance
will cover the entire property let's say
if your house were to get destroyed in a
fire it will cover that now there could
very well be certain deductibles or
certain limits to it but it's a really
important asset for a lot of folks to
ensure pretty well it can obviously cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars or more
and you oftentimes borrowed money
against it and so you don't want to be
in a situation where you borrowed money
you know you put hundreds of thousands
of dollars down payment you borrowed
extra money you bought a house and then
a flood or earthquake a fire something
destroys the house you still owe that
money but you no longer have a house so
you can imagine homeowners insurance can
be not only valuable and many times the
bank that gave a loan would say you have
to have homeowners insurance because we
don't want you to be in that situation
but even if you don't have if you're a
homeowner and even if someone isn't
forcing you to get homeowners insurance
it's a pretty good idea because a home
is a pretty valuable asset
and there's going to be different types
of homeowners insurance some will cover
everything I just mentioned some will
cover if you live in a high flood risk
Zone some will cover everything but
flood and then you have to get a
separate flood insurance I live out here
in California sometimes a policy will
cover everything but earthquakes and
then you have to get a separate
earthquake insurance for that but it's
the same idea if one of this these
really bad things happen and you were to
lose the house or lose the property
inside the house this insurance would
have you covered